on pense à réfléchir à l'impact de nos
gestes au quotidien insisté sur le tri
des déchets un des objectifs de cette
semaine du développement durable
attrape une journée de l'environnement a
été mise en place
aujourd'hui on met en valeur surtout
notre centre technique municipal
nous on a mis en place des panneaux qui
explique l'historique de ce centre et on
a également une marque
on voulait mettre en place des ateliers
en lien avec la biodiversité
sensibilisation aux déchets mais aussi
atelier jardinage visite des animaux ou
encore sculpture autant d'activités
proposées pour tous les âges dans le
cadre de cette semaine du développement
durable avec la possibilité de déguster
des produits bio venus pour rejouer et
apprend des trucs pour trier et pour
apprendre les pelotes et la nature les
enfants notamment apprécié l'atelier
jardinage où ils avaient la possibilité
de repartir avec leurs plantes
ça consiste à les initier à la
plantation c'est-à-dire à transvaser une
plante qui est dans un godet qui a été
acheté dans une jardinerie en général et
à la transvaser si vous voulez dans un
contenant un peu plus haut voilà et
tout en leur expliquant le posséder
et on les dit dans avoisine le
bretonneux c'est pour eux la deuxième
édition de la semaine du développement
à cette occasion un atelier cuisine afin
de lutter contre le gaspillage
alimentaire s'est déroulée en
partenariat avec l'association jardins
opération partage sa de matinée c'est de
permettre à des seigneurs de pouvoir
élaborer un plat rapidement on va dire
une heure et demie avec une entrée un
plat un dessert sur la table différents
éléments ont des paniers garnis chacun a
choisi ses éléments à commencer par
réfléchir à ses besoins la semaine du
développement durable se poursuit
jusqu'au 5 juin sur tout le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines